hello everyone welcome to bio conference
live just as an introductory comment let
me note that at the end of this about 40
minutes from now we'll have a question
and answer period so start saving up
your questions and answers right now in
fact you can enter them online in the
Q&A box if you haven't you not familiar
with that familiar is yourself with it
now so the topic for this bio conference
live talk is technology and open access
to cohorts for combining genomes other
ohms environmental and trade data this
is my conflict of interest slide I have
many organizations that have helped
bring the technologies that I've been
that we've been working on into the
public domains for for the public in for
researchers so the the next slide is
about this revolution in genomics and
omics more broadly defined here we're
talking about epigenomics proteomics
transcriptomics and so forth and this is
not just in analytic but it's also
synthetic it affects our ability to
manipulate the ohms and we're going to
talk about one particular open access
route which is the Personal Genome
Project or PGP and how this impacts our
transition to clinical quality
transfer and therapeutic prioritization
and I'll give you two examples of new
technology including in-situ sequencing
on 3rd slide here we have that's
something that's often confused in this
revolution of especially on interpreting
inherited genomics there's also
pharmacogenomics and cancer genomics but
specific on inherited genomics there now
over 2,400 genetic diseases which are
considered highly predictive and
medically actual so much so that this is
the practice of medical genetics and is
now suitable for for high-throughput
sequencing methods in the past these
have been restricted to people with
family histories and one gene at a time
largely for economic reasons and
background information we now are
getting that background information and
we can deploy it that these affect at
least ten percent of us and there as I
said a highly predictive and medically
actionable and this had been going on
since the mid-90s here's an example of
one of the Personal Genome Project
participants with a little bit more of
that project in a moment that this is
john lauerman of who described us in his
Bloomberg column he had a jack to
mutation which not in his inherited
genome but was developing somatically in
his blood and could lead to one of
several different diseases was caught
far earlier than it would have normally
been caught because we were sequenced
his his blood genome in this project
Steven Pinker is also comment on this in
the New York Times and other places he
his experience was finding out a
potential risk factor for hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy which is a diseases that
strikes healthy individuals without
warning sometimes resulting in very
premature death even among athletes
now this revolution in principle is it
is invading do-it-yourself biology not
just the research market not just
direct-to-consumer but even kids here is
do-it-yourself kit for your kids that
and there are many other ones that are
aimed at all ages where your kid can
figure out who the father is or other
innocent activities this photo from the
wall street journal is a student who
spent three summers in our lab and west
who analyzed all four of our family
members including her father who had
factor 5 Leiden which is a risk factor
for four long plane trips which he does
quite a few of but more significantly we
have a growing number of successes of
new personal genomics not just the
conventional medical genetics that might
require up to three thousand dollars per
gene test now we can get an entire
genomes for three to four thousand
dollars and we have examples like Nick
Folker who had missed diagnosis of all
kind and all kinds of in intestinal
surgeries up until one of his
pediatricians decided to get a whole
genome or exome sequence done and then
it changed to a focus on immune system
and a blood stem cell transplant
resulted in a huge change in his
prognosis and more or less normal life--
the beery twins were misdiagnosed with
cerebral palsy and then slowly move
towards whole genome our whole exome
sequencing to find that all of us needed
was a dietary change from to a dopamine
and serotonin analogs and finally I
should note that the Food Drug
Administration removes white moves quite
promptly when we have technologies that
actually work for example here's a very
rare cystic fibrosis allele that uh for
which there is now a drug specific for
that particular
DNA sequence and the FDA approved that
in a three-month period and they're
quite rightfully proud of this
achievement of the Food and Drug
Administration I also want to note PG ad
is a force in the community now to get
this education deployed into high
schools across the United States in the
world so where do we go from here we are
not merely talking about going from your
inherited genome to your traits we are
not talking about perfect prediction in
the absence of all of their medical
diagnostics it's more of an integrated
community and weekend up so we do have
it it's now a million times less
expensive to do the whole human genome
and so it's now affordable too many
people around the world but we have the
opportunity to fill in additional data
classical medical traits and
measurements as well as a variety of new
ones that are becoming a wireless 724
monitoring and and so on but the omics
that made genomes a million times
cheaper also makes many environmental
and metabolic measurements internal to
your body also a million times less
expensive and we'll see those prices
slowly drop in in the marketplace and
this includes your mic your the
microbiomes that surround you in the
world your immune response to them the
metabolic response of your body to these
inflammatory events foods allergens and
your environment and so forth all of
these have ohmic components and how we
respond developmentally in terms of
aging these are reflected in the
epigenomics meaning the RNA and protein
in the various tissues of your body as
you develop an age finally imaging is
something that will talk about where
there's a merger now of ferrous imaging
methods and the ohmic methods
so this project there is only one
project that I'm aware of worldwide that
is capable of sharing data broadly this
this open access project is you can find
information about it or a volunteer at
personal genomes org it has some
international components and it is
distinguished by what individuals have
been consented that are willing to have
their genomes their cells of various
primary and cell lines available through
worldwide without restriction commercial
they're available for commercial use
without any strings attached and we have
approval for a hundred thousand
volunteers in the Boston Brandt's alone
and there many other branches and the
main requirement is that people get a
hundred percent on an interest exam
which is considerably easier now than it
it used to be and is a just to make sure
that you've read the consent form
essentially now what we're talking about
here is measurements not merely the
omics measurements but an increasing
number of wireless measurements that
that measure how the omics plays out
through it and how you're how you differ
from day to day in the second to second
and these include measurements of your
EEG of brain activity and sleep activity
some people of fall asleep during the
daytime fMRI as another brain
measurement typically not done
wirelessly cardiovascular measurements
ultrasound and skin monitors these are
all making giant leaps forward and will
many of them will become increasing
considered an extension or your cell
phone going back to genomics as and the
omics measurements we we are looking for
exceptional individuals where each of us
have rare alleles that are specific to
ourselves or our families and some of
these are not just deleterious but
they're rare protective alleles might
associate these with P
who live for over a hundred and ten
years for example and here's an it
here's one that has been reproduced a
kind of a standard for scientific
practice to be reproduced in animal
models so the humans that exhibit this
or this case flex boiler does also work
out but you can see that the lean body
mass which is somewhat independent of
diet is reflected in the in the cow the
dog and the mouse models for this so
this double null book of the myostatin
gene has these very interesting
phenotypes of decreased body fat and
decreased atherosclerosis so this is an
interesting genotype to explore and
there many more so when we're looking
beyond correlations to causative alleles
and particularly is highly protective
rare alleles which are not easily
captured in most of the standard pre
Personal Genome Project methodologies
and in it so other examples beyond the
myostatin double no they just talked
about whether there are lrp5 gene
alleles which can be in the heterozygote
state meaning both mutant and wild-type
from mother and father which result in
extra strong bones so capable of
breaking surgical drill bits peak pcsk9
gene alleles are extreme significance
and importance as we get 85 or so
percent lowering of coronary artery
disease risk the huge risk of change
ccr5 we'll talk about in just a moment
but it and fut two are examples of
alleles that rare alleles are relatively
rare not not the major allele in the
population that that make us make the
individuals that have double nulls
resistant to a variety of viruses such
as norovirus in the case of fut to an
HIV in the case of ccr5
so I note this blog down at the bottom
that gives more background information
at personal genomes org so follow
drilling down a little bit deeper on the
ccr5 example we have the double null has
been observed to cause resistance to a
large class of hiv/aids causing viruses
and these this observation in natural
populations there they're almost
non-existent in Asian African
populations but the the few individuals
that have this prompted now a phase 2
clinical trial from sangamo making a
zinc finger nuclease a design protein
ensign that will cleave specifically in
the ccr5 gene in cells derived from the
body of these patients about blood stem
cells that can be then manipulated
genetically precisely this is not the
old-fashioned gene therapy where viruses
would indicate randomly throughout the
genome but these are very precise change
in just one gene both copies from
maternal and paternal so that now we
have both copies of your ccr5 HIV
co-receptor are gone and so even a
patient that started out with full-blown
AIDS possible even drug-resistant AIDS
can now become fully resistant because
the few T cell precursors in that in
that autologous transplant are now fully
aids resistant and the ones that were
not affected it's slowly die off and and
we have people to survive not not this
clinical trial but previous stem cell
transplants for over five years
now another way to impact our
interaction between our immune system of
the microbiome is we can measure both
directly the microorganisms was just
advantage for drug resistance drug
resistance is not it's not easily
observed in the alternative set of
Diagnostics which focus on our immune
response we use Diagnostics that are
focused on very specific pathogens like
HIV or tuberculosis TB by looking at the
immune the body's immune response to
them that's appropriate if you have a
hit-and-run or very rare hard to detect
virus or bacterium but you have these
two options of doing diagnosis with
either the microbial level or the immune
and we'd like to generalize the immune
tests just as we've generalized the
inherited genome test from single gene
tests where you have a preexisting
conditions to to whole genome test now
we want to extend single microorganism
tests to your entire microbiome or at
least a very large set of potential
pathogens now we do this if we do this
more general version of it by sequencing
your entire immune response from Apple
it'll blood tests depending on whether
we're looking for the cellular response
or antibody response we can do is
somewhere in the range of one microliter
to a milliliter of blood this this
diagram is kind of a textbook diagram of
the human immune genes in their germline
and the rearranged state they we have
now on the order of 24 of the heavy
chains rearranging with the the 23d
regions and 6j regions so this video
J rearrangements combined with a light
chain can produce about three million
combinations but in addition as you
connect these you fill in with novel
nucleotides which can range from zero
filim to 140 some base pair fillin via
de novo complete independent polymerase
action of the terminal transferase
polymerase and so the the incredible
diversity that's generated are not just
by genomic rearranges of existing gene
fragments but these new components that
sometimes called n regions produce by
terminal transferase and we can monitor
these we've done this in collaboration
with Roche and this was work from Yuri
leiserson and Francois vignon where we
show where we can do this on blood
samples as a function of time and a mod
and keeping track of specific events
such as the vaccines or exposure to
diseases so this week this falls into
the endosome extrusion orientation slide
it into the epigenomics and proteomics
and immune omics so here so i mentioned
that these in regions and whether you
get rearrangement of the vm d NJ can be
quite large and here's an example of one
of those large ones it's 84 base pairs
long it could be as little as 0 this
particular one had provided a second way
in addition to the the one we talked
about earlier this is a way of getting
neutralizing antibodies that makes rare
individuals in our population resistant
to HIV and these neutralizing antibodies
have been
characterized and are the basis of some
some new way of obtaining immunity not
via vaccines where you count on the
vaccine is producing reproducibly in a
large fraction of the population an
immune response which has been very
difficult in the case of HIV to a new
procedure where instead of posing the
problem to your body you give it the
answer you can say instead of having the
potty try to figure out what's the right
antibody to make to deal with HIV or HIV
vaccine you give it the answer which is
this is an antibody this worked well you
know in a in one in a million individual
now we can deploy it along a broader set
David Baltimore news group and other
groups are excited about this pathway
and and are testing it by injecting aav
vector loads with these antibody genes
into muscle cells now the muscle cells
do a very on something that's very
unnatural for muscles they imitate B
cells and produce antibodies but this
looks very promising in the road model
so far and we look forward to primate
human testing now that that rare
antibody is rare in part because it was
so long that that long usually would be
a deep groove and Alice along protrusion
from the antibody can snake into a
conserved region of the HIV surface
glycoprotein and
since its conserved it's one it's one of
the few things that the HIV virus was
just highly mutable doesn't change but
that required does not necessarily
something that every person would would
body would come up with in response to a
vaccine it required in this distribution
this is it this particular distribution
is is the length of the of these cdr3
these these position where the B and D
and J come together this is a time chart
of a time series analysis for vaccine
vaccination trials as this is a from the
Personal Genome Project not an HIV
project and you see factors of 10 along
the y-axis and lengths ranging from 0 to
145 base pairs in this highly variable
region and you can see that 84 is is
well into the region where these
antibodies tend to be unique for a
particular individual and we detect
these in a variety of samples that we're
doing with this immune sequencing which
is now only feasible because the great
drop in the cost of genomics so we've
been following a vaccination time course
for some of these individuals for over
three and a half years now and you can
see here's a little piece of that time
series where we've aligned three
different individuals at a time zero of
accident seasonal flu vaccine and you
can see for the two younger ones that at
the bottom a a ballooning outs or a
textbook expansion of the
flew responsive antibodies at around
seven days after vaccination and then
the top one which happens to be my
immune ohm for some reason or other has
a much less distinctive one the color
coding here is indicates that we can
follow individual antibody gene
sequences no matter where they go in the
body no matter how long the time that
elapses and even if other parts of the
immune gene antibody encoding gene
changes with time we can still monitor
this sort of natural barcode tag which
is this hyper variable region throughout
time and color code anything that's seen
in multiple time points now we'd like to
combine that deeper understanding we
have of the heavy and light chain we can
couple now those two together and we
look and we can now couple them to
specific antigens so we can take either
a natural fluid containing antigen
binding molecules like antibodies or we
can take these hybrid molecules that we
rescue from peripheral blood and
manipulate at the nucleic acid if you
see DNA level anyway we could take in a
library of binding molecules is called
am antibodies and and a library that we
make of potential antigen molecules they
can be antigens from your own body these
would be autoantigens self proteins to
which you should not be responding
immunologically and
we can make a library of these antigens
and bind them to a library of antibodies
or other binding molecules and pull down
the specific binding events and then and
then correlate which antibodies bind to
which antigens and this is done in
collaboration with ben lar minh and
steve elledge in harvard department
genetics and this can be expanded and is
being expanded now from human Auto
antigen reactivity to bacterial viral
and attack allergens and foods which may
or may not be allergens so you can make
these large libraries of potential
antibody crop bit binding to combine
these antigens and could potentially
cross reacts this is I think a very
interesting new technology and again
benefits greatly from our progress in
omics so how kind of put the cart before
the horse intentionally here how did
wanted to motivate how did we get to
this point where we take for granted all
these new omics technologies you can use
them in various novel ways we have a
variety of new technologies to that I
just like to mention here is this in
situ sequencing and nanopore sequencing
what so what how are these getting
closer to the clinic where we have to
have very high accuracy when we make
predictions about how quickly
technologies go we can air either on the
optimistic or pessimistic side
when we were extrapolating from about
the time that we were finishing off a
very rough draft of her around the year
2000 a rough draft of human genome if we
took the stance of a very aggressive
exponential curve such as the
exponential you get in the electronics
and computer industry of 1.5 fold
multiplicative every year that seemed
like a pretty aggressive curve and that
would result in a fordable genome in
about 40 years from from that 3 billion
dollar genome success as it turns out
that curve was even though it seemed
quite aggressive was actually on a
pessimistic side instead of being 40
years it was more like six to ten years
and is in that and there's a change in
slope these are factors of 10 in in base
pairs per dollar on the y-axis and years
on it on the horizontal axis and so what
we're seeing is prices dropping from
around two thousand a year to then the
hundreds of year hundreds of dollars per
human genome in the next year or two and
there's really no let up in this
eventually there will be a plateau of
some sort of other but it's quite quite
interesting to follow this and its
impact on a variety of other types of
omics
the reason this happened is we move from
a monopoly a sort of complacent single
technology to now dozens of different
technologies represented both
academically and in this case of 44
commercial leave supported technologies
over the past years not all of these are
are in existence at the same time in the
red box the ones that are 9 that are
currently available either as a service
or as an instrument and in in green or
ones that will hopefully be available
within the next year or so that are
focused on nanopore technology the one
of the redbox tend to be focused on
either multi molecule or fluorescent
technologies sequencing by synthesis or
sometimes call now when we compare these
two methodology be keeping in mind the
progress that's already been made we've
gone from this you know sort of
centimeter scale sequencing technology
on Joe Lhota freesat swear I did my
graduate work with Wally Gilbert to noun
hundreds of nanometer dots in grids
which can be detected fluorescently
getting close to the conventional for us
microscopy limit this has been done and
we had a number of papers in
collaboration with rotted romantic at
Complete Genomics on this including one
recently in in nature where
a error rate of one in 10 million was
established but looking forward we have
this knit nanopore technology is a
possibility for getting acceptably long
reads and and we just need to watch and
work on the technology to improve the
quality which I think as far as I can
tell is is as improvable as any other
that we have now in handheld size
prototypes of these they're close to
disposable order of hundreds of dollars
and some of the technology that previz
Jesus back in the 90s of using
polymerase in concert with a poor to
measure the ion conductance as potassium
or sodium ions go through the the poor
and double-stranded DNA can be can be
either inserted directly stripped so the
single strand is going through the poor
and interfering with the ion conductance
or you can have small molecules released
from the single or double stranded DNA
going into the poor as a a number of
academic groups have contributed us
including you know young gun locks group
and Hagan Bailey's and Oxford nanopore
and Gina are two of the commercial ones
and demonstrations have been announced
although there's nothing in the
scientific literature yet of up to a
hundred thousand base pair reads this is
extremely important for filling in long
gaps and we expect to see the
the error rate improve from currently
somewhere around four percent and to too
much much higher qualities nevertheless
there are some things that are not
immediately accessible to this new
nanopore technology and I'll give an
example of that where where it looks
like the fluorescence methodologies that
are already in play may be immediately
applicable and we call this fluorescent
in situ sequencing or physique um and
I'll give some examples that in just a
moment now part of the motivation for
for in-situ sequencing was being able to
get very long continuity not over
hundreds of kilobytes not over hundreds
of vases or hundred kilobases but over
hundreds of mega bases basically over
the whole chromosome there are three
ways of doing this the the two that are
in the most recent literature are using
foz meds or bacterial artificial
chromosomes or sheared and actually
shared DNA where where one can work from
as little as 10 cells or even five cells
as your input source and this is not
only feasible but it's desirable to do a
very small number of cells where you
distribute the DNA / say a340 84 well
multiwell plate and about point one
genome equivalent about tenth of a
genome equivalent per well whole genome
amplification and then bar coding and
going into standard complete genomic
sequencing or four probably other
methods as well and this results in a in
a long haplotypes on the order of mega
base size haplotypes and a very high
error rates one and ten million so
that's so recently published in Nature
extending that from the now millions of
bases couple million bases to whole
chromosomes it was demonstrated using
this in situ sequencing methodology
using metaphase chromosomes where you
have in the entire chromosome separating
the material in that pattern alors
separating one chromosome from many
others and you can ask a series of
sequencing questions and essentially a
series of of sequences from each
chromosome as if it's a dot and this
allows us to get appli typing from
telomere to telomere and validated in
this slide using a trio where it which
is yet another way of getting appetites
that unfortunately one that's not always
available but to get it from from an
individual where you may not have family
genetic resources you can do this
dilution method of metaphase chromosomes
right and just just a reminder as we in
the middle here is keep your questions
start entering online we'll be there
very soon so finally this in situ
sequencing extended now from chromosomes
to other aspects of human biology here
is where we're doing individual cells
we're looking for cancer cells that are
not only different from the normal cells
in your blood or in tissues by virtue of
being cancerous and pelipper too but
they're all so different that they are
now drug-resistant this is from a study
that we did in collaboration of George
daily where we're looking at the BCR
Abel tyrosine kinase change in these
cells that make the oncogenic
transformation and this kindness is
initially sensitive to the drugs and
becomes resistant so little green dots
in here you can see in some of these
images are cancer cells that are drug
resistant so we're detecting a one base
pair difference that makes both the
difference in the drug resistance and
allows us to do the diagnostic where we
can detect very rare cell and the
objective here is detect those so cells
as early as possible in the parts per
million and hopefully parts per billion
in in in in blood or tissues so that's
one other applications of chromosomes
haplotype being finding rare cancer
cells or rare drug-resistant cancer
cells the final application is in
characterizing your epigenome how your
your body is responding to development
and aging and what the potentialities of
your of your personal genome is too
to the responsiveness of your tissue to
to drugs and so forth and to do this we
want to get access to all of your cells
but this is not feasible for living
individuals patients so what we do in
Personal Genome Project as we establish
bio manx of particularly useful cells
either print that we have primary
tissues available for saliva blood skin
and so forth and then we have derived
cells particularly used for these
induced pluripotent stem cells which
have allow us to get access to a wide
variety of cell types here's some some
data from the quality control QC from
the coryell biobank where nine different
tissues are routinely assayed by a
pathological histological examination
here's showing the three major cell
lineages endoderm ectoderm mesoderm and
you can see these neuronal rosettes
pigmented cells ductal cells and so
forth beautifully organized within these
teratomas that are experimentally
induced within mice we can also take
these human cell lines and make more
complicated organized tissues in vitro
for example the personalized organs on
ship the organs on ship project is
spearheaded but Don Ingber and Geraldine
hamilton at the visa to biologically
inspired engineering where I'm a
coworker and so and together we're
trying to combine the organs on chip
with a Personal Genome Project to make
these personalized organs on ship which
will be a value to drug testing these
organs on ships have
a multi cellular components they have a
mechanical components or you can
actually have multiple phases for
example in the lung you have an air
passage epithelia lung epithelial layer
alveolar so on another another layer and
then endothelial and then blood and the
mechanical forces that come along with
breathing are simulated and without
these mechanical forces and correct
geometry and extracellular matrix and so
forth you don't get proper cellular
differentiation and physiological
behavior so this is a very exciting
trend and I urge you all to tune into it
now we can analyze the faithfulness of
those synthetic laboratory you know
organs on ship with natural cells in his
deep a manner as we wish and in part
this is because it's in situ sequencing
method that it showed earlier for
chromosomes and cancer cells and also be
applied to to the RNA up for multiple
rnase at once we have not yet achieved
sequencing on every RNA of every of
every cell in a specimen but we clearly
it's capable of the kind of
next-generation sequencing we've been
talking about which is in turn capable
of doing RNA sequencing getting multiple
splice forms for essentially all the
RNAs even micro RNA is present in a
cellular sample this is now not only
single cell where you might take snap us
you know dissect the sell-off of a slide
and make a library put it back on
another flow cell slide for sequencing
now we leave it in place on the slide
and sequence it where each dot which was
a single molecule is left in place so
you get the geometric context and the
relationship to other cells you get
subcellular resolution and many RNAs are
unevenly distributed in physiologically
meaningful ways out of the cell and this
is a new tank
that will allow us to get it now what's
limited in situ in the past is the
limited number of colors typically one
or two or three even four but with in
situ sequencing you now get to reuse
those four colors over and over just as
you do in next-generation fluorescent
sequencing in general and so in effect
you get not four colors but for to the
in colors where n is the number of
cycles of of sequencing so we've now
done this for 60 cycles so you can think
of that as for to the 60th power or you
can think of it as a barcode that's
unique enough that you can tell which
dot corresponds to which messenger RNA
and here we've taken a challenging test
we being mass Nelson and jelly Jewish
gang and vegetarian our team challenging
tests where we have two cells that are
very similar to one of those two
fibroblasts differ by one base pair and
the difference between the green and the
red dots each of them represent a single
RNA molecule you can see that that
delimited by the cell boundaries that
one cell will tend to have only read
Neil and only green which means they
differ by one base pair in one messenger
RNA type and you can see every instance
or many instances of single messenger
RNA molecules in these two different
cell types step aside but that's just
that's just using two colors we have as
I said effectively for to the 60th
colors available here these can be
lightly amplified so that they still are
dots as far as the resolution of the
microscope is concerned the light
amplification however makes them very
strong signals that are easy to detect
for sequencing these can be immobilized
in a variety of novel fixatives that we
use for this and this cross linking
allows us to have this cdna covalently
attached to the
the plastic like protein cross-linked
matrix so we can get these many rounds
of sequencing by synthesis and
fluorescent note either single by
ligation or by polymerase here you see
some three dimensional we've done a
confocal and other microscopy
measurements here and we have very this
is showing how over 60 cycles we get
essentially no change and
signal-to-noise we the reproducibility
this is quite high and this gives us the
the multiple colors that we need for
unambiguous identification of each
messenger RNA now if we have information
overload their two solutions to this one
is improving the resolution of the
microscopy and the other is improving is
doing selectively a sequencing of
subsets of the RNAs by doing subsets you
can do multiple subsets and eventually
get the full set but any given moment
you're only looking at a subset and so
the the viewing image plane is less
complicated also the thinner the
sections if you're doing sectioning the
thin of the sections and the less
complicated is the image and you can see
and at the very bottom of the slide how
as we read as we get more and more
specific subsets we get smaller and
smaller number of
of these detected RNAs so with four
colors at a time so that's one approach
is by doing molecular tricks to select
subsets by using semi random primers
that select or specific gene-specific
primers to select subsets ultimately
getting as close to full transcriptome
as you would like and then the second
method is using super resolution this
can be achieved either by optics which
we've done in collaboration with
Lightspeed genomics where they have a
ring of a spatially pattern light
provided in by a laser patterning which
and you can see was huge improvement
from the raw images in the middle to the
aperture optics on the far right hand
side of the slide where you get these
sharp dots maybe tenfold improvement in
resolution here due to optics and and
and finally so that's one method the
other method is using a flickering
fluorescent molecules such as the the
Nikon storm that our colleague at
Harvard shall way song has entered and
has developed and this has somewhere
between 10 and 20 nanometer resolution
which is really quite extraordinary for
these in-situ visualizations and and
hopefully will be quite useful for
in-situ of sequencing
so just in conclusion use this slide as
a convenient way of encapsulating and
summarizing where we talked about it
will also use it in the question it'll
be stay up during the question answering
session hopefully you've been writing in
your questions already online where we
where we've been on this little journey
today is looking at the special cohort
at personal genomes org we urge you all
to consider volunteering for this where
we can capture human genomes
environments and traits and share them
broadly without restriction the for
without restriction about having to do
with Rhea Denton or commercial uses we
not only have their personal and
heritage genome but we have growing
resources on their microbiome from five
different body sites the immunological
response to their environment including
food and other metabolic components that
can influence immune response and
inflammation and then and then how this
microbiome any meu nome affects their
developmental and aging process in the
epigenome RNA and protein and immune
components and finally this imaging not
just the in situ sequency i was talking
about but very complicated physiological
monitoring such as functional magnetic
resonance imaging and that's this week
we consider a part of the traits and the
trade data set for these individuals is
growing and as more and more is learned
about these individuals that come become
like rosetta stones they become more
valuable and yet attract even more
attention so i'm gonna leave this slide
up as i open it up for questions and
answers please feel free to jump in at
any time and i'll just start with the
ones that we have already here
so we have one from karina nickel off at
fo metrics which asks how can you detect
single base differences in RNA how long
is the sequence so the specific
instances i was showing for the in-situ
sequencing we can do up to 60 cycles of
next-gen sequencing on these fixed
issues so we're talking on the order of
60 base pair long sequence tags the the
reason we can see single base
differences because we are in the same
way you can see single base differences
in conventional sequencing but this is
conventional next-generation sequencing
you're adding a fluorescent base or
ligating on a base specific short
hexamer oligonucleotide and this this
gives a very crisp single based
discrimination and on so that's how we
do it
another question here from Robert Noble
from a more philosophical viewpoint how
do you see the action of expression on a
genetic basis how does it impact our
psychosocial components and paraphrasing
here slightly many of which happen in in
very short periods of time most of the
methods work we're talking about here
are either snapshots a fist fixed issue
which but there are certainly some of
the traits that we want to be able to
explain cause and effect where one's
inherited genome can impact over long
periods of time your day to day even
millisecond interacts with your
environment by combining such real-time
monitoring as EEG EKG fMRI that varies
from person to person in combination
with environment and seeing how that
person person variation is as reflected
in the genomes and epigenome
Michael fert off from like or
biosciences asks will genome sequencing
be able to predict post translational
modification of proteins such as
phosphorylation and glycosylation I I
think what we're talking about here is
not so much genome sequencing as
sequencing next-generation sequencing
which can include nucleic acid tagged
antibodies so by some of the same
methods that I mentioned earlier where
we can find what your own immune system
is thinking as it's exposed to the
environment we can also use this for
finding ever richer sets of antibodies
that are specific for specific proteins
their post translational modifications
such as poor phosphorylation and clock
oscillation many of these have already
been established through more classical
polyclonal monoclonal antibody searches
but I think this will ramp up very very
quickly with these new next-gen
methodologies and this will allow us
should we allow us to detect in situ
proteins the same way we're beginning to
detect in situ rnase it will probably be
initially protein subsets you know now
that on the order of thousands of
proteins are available we might even
want to take subsets of those but I
think that's a very interesting line of
exploration
okay please keep your questions coming
in here's one about what are the
prospects and status for interpretation
of personal genome data I think this is
one of the key things that we need
education and communication about how
how well interpretation does work it's
very easy to look at the half empty part
of the glass what that that there are
many things we can't do with either
genome sequencing or or other kinds of
genomics and omics but there we but
there's so many things we can do and
this is true of almost every medical
diagnostic practice there's a subset of
applications at work and so with the
with the inherited genome the half-full
part of the glass is that we have 2400
diseases which are highly predictive and
medically actionable and these need no
longer be restricted to family to people
who have had family exam examples of
these genetic diseases because there are
many examples where you'll be the first
person your family because the presence
of a recessive allele from both your
mother and your father you're the first
person to have it and so you can't
exclude those and you and since you
can't exclude any particular gene it
means basically all of us are at risk
for every genetic disease which is and
and and and those that are diagnosable
right now the 2400 that are highly
usable could be used pre-conception or
premarital ii as you're making
reproductive choices there's a question
here about how how long until the newest
technologies are available and and will
any of the current technologies to be
displaced I think we have a history
already in the very short time that
we've had next-generation sequencing of
the various companies merging and and
producing hybrid methodologies a salute
and there inevitably will be some
displacement I think that the two the
two versions are coming on quickly now
or this in situ sequencing which will
have a whole new set of applications not
currently captured by the current
methodology and then of course the
nanopore could open up new markets not
necessarily displacing anybody because
of the high portability or the very
rapid response to potential
environmental pathogens possibly as
little as a few minute delay between the
incoming particles and the outgoing
sequence interpretation so
I see
ok
yeah why don't you read it because I I
need to be logging in here okay
right so uh can you use fresh tissue
samples with physique because from her
fourth row from he looks to to health so
ah it yes you can use fresh tissue as
fresh at a time you start using it it is
fixed at the time that you're doing the
the sequencing itself yeah so it's a
it's initially fresh but does so you're
not certainly not limited to cell lines
or to you know to old paths pathological
samples fresh tissue is quite usable
here's a question from Arlene hang low
regarding the use of HIV antibody cdr3
for therapy with the three year period
of immuno genetic detection supersede
vaccine production let me reframe the
slightly so we the antibody therapy is
still just in rodent testing it looks
quite promising it in principle it
should be usable as long as the muscle
cells keep producing antibodies we don't
know how long that will be it could be
the lifetime of the individual it could
actually be longer than conventional
immune cells in that the muscle cells
turnover more slowly say than some of
the memory b cells I think that's
speculative what time will tell but it's
a it it could be better than
conventional vaccines how many you can
have operating at once it will kind of
load you can handle in your muscle and
in your blood is also an open question
and
so here's a question from Robert noble
is a pgp only for human genomes that
will include all genomes from the local
biome for immune cross-referencing are
certainly we already have examples of
multiple microbiome it components and
immune and we're beginning to get the
immune cross reaction panel up and it's
certainly our ambition as a community
and this can be broadly shared like
Wikipedia to get the first set of
genomes including plants and animals
that constitute our food in our
environment yeah
right so parvin meta por from tehran
asks how do you a say telomeres with
physique this is we are where haven't
done telomeres with physique yet but it
would be very similar to the way that we
would analyze telomeres in any next
generation sequencing which currently
next-generation sequencing has trouble
with long tandem repeats and so one of
the things we hope the sequel do is by
having stretched long repeats we can we
can handle a variety of new projects
here's a question of how can we
participate in the Personal Genome
Project you can go to personal genomes
org learn more about it and eventually
take an entrance exam darling but bunton
university health system's since enjoyed
the presentation Joseph Abby from
venture group says next-generation
sequencing and other related genomic
technologies how global is the effort to
generate a more accurate primary data
for diagnostic and academic research
this is a very interesting and timely
question the the US National Institute
of Standards and Technology or NIST is
currently generating a standard that
will be widely shared one of the ones
under consideration and this is a
transparent conversation that's going on
publicly go to the news site to get more
information called genome in a bottle
and they and they are that one of the
sample types is under considerations are
trios possibly is a trios initially from
the Personal Genome Project which will
allow us to generate more and more
accurate primary data I mentioned one in
10 to the 7th meaning one at ten million
is sort of where we are it would be nice
to get closer to one in a billion or one
per less than one per genome one error
per genome
so thank you all for your your questions
and comments and I would encourage you
to continue to to participate in this
wonderful community that we have here
and attend to other of bio conference
live it's it's a it's a the personal
genomics and do-it-yourself biology
community and involves researchers
around the world and the sharing that
you can do is as highly encouraged thank
you again and have a good day
you